basically when i talk about building
psychological safety on a team
what that means is leaders create an
environment which the people working in
the company the people on a team
feel safe enough to raise their hand and
say i made a mistake
or i don't understand what i'm doing or
i'm struggling at home and it's
affecting my work or
i'm scared or i need help without any
fear of humiliation or retribution
in fact they can say these things with
absolute confidence that their boss or
their co-workers will rush to support
them
that's what a trusting team feels like
we've all been on one before we also
all know what it feels like not to be on
a trusting team where we would never
admit mistakes for fear of humiliation
or getting in trouble
we're never going to say i don't
understand something um we're not going
to admit we're scared we're not going to
tell anybody that we're struggling at
home it's affecting our work and we're
definitely not asking for help
because these things make us vulnerable
or weak it might put us on a short list
for the next round of layoffs or worse
my boss it might hurt my career chances
i won't get promoted
because i've i've said i don't
understand something so we keep quiet
might work in the short term but over
the course of time a company where no
employee ever admits mistakes
or worse they hide their mistakes
eventually those cracks grow and grow
and grow and and
cause great damage to the organization
and its ability
uh to succeed so this is a leader's
responsibility
it's a leader's responsibility to create
an environment in which people feel
psychologically safe
and if somebody makes a mistake we can
help them fix it as alan mullally used
to talk about when he took over
ford murder company uh you are not the
problem you have a problem and if you
can tell me the problem
we can all rally together to help you
fix it
you